do you think you can mention uh
some people still view me as guests
could you say Greg from real Rejects
okay cool
just to make me feel better about myself
welcome to the across the Spoilers
Podcast I'm your host Greg from real
rejects uh before the episode Greg made
sure that I said Greg from real Rejects
and not just Greg Alba so yeah I'm Greg
from real rejects everyone how's it
going
hi I'm I'm Paul from heavy spoilers you
got a certain Cadence you got a little
more nasal and then I yeah exactly
Theory time theory time that's all I
know how to do really yeah that's the
closest
t-shirt from shopzeroedition.com if you
want to support the channel uh my name
is my nasalist this is going to be even
worse this week because uh I've got a
cold the bloody the kids they've cut
they're just bringing everything from
the nursery
you need to get rid of those twins
yeah
thanks thanks sir Craig I'm sure my wife
will be
very pleased to watch this back um she
doesn't watch your stuff I know her she
doesn't watch any of this does she watch
any of your stuff does she actually no I
don't know
never never wants to watch it ever which
is fair enough because I wouldn't want
to watch it either
um
because it's pretty crap to be fair now
we're gonna have the best show ever this
week though I promise you guys a good
transition yeah
um so lots of box office they used to
talk about Greg is anything you want to
start us off with yeah man I want to
start us off with listening off things
we're going to be probably talking about
because we got um more we got some
surprise box office hits and some bigger
surprise box office drops looks like
Indiana Jones might be one of I mean the
big talk has been the flash being the
biggest huge box office bomb it looks
like Indiana Jones because of how much
it costs might even be a bigger bomb
you just saw Mission Impossible seven if
I'm not mistaken yeah you just talk
about Mission Impossible seven get your
thoughts out there and then uh a little
bit before filming uh you told me this
morning and then I am doing a lot I
literally just entered a live stream a
few minutes ago pretty much on an empty
stomach
Deadpool Wolverine we got our first look
at his new outfit and there's a couple
of other things that maybe we'll dive
into maybe
um but these are the main ones on the
agenda Paul I know you love talking
about box office goodies two movies came
out this weekend which have knocked off
in so Indiana Jones is number three in
the box office right now is that what it
is I'm not 100 sure though
in city I don't know what any of these
movies are I mean other than Insidious
what sound of freedom
uh so yeah we'll talk about it in just a
bit um but basically Insidious the red
door that has opened now it did 32.6
million opening weekend on a 16 million
dollar budget it's now knocked Indiana
Jones off the top spot which is CR if
you told me uh the fifth Insidious movie
would beat the fifth Indiana Jones film
at the box office I would have thought
nah nah no way and what we talked about
last week it's obviously Horrors
normally does quite well
um but obviously these guys have came in
very very you know low budget uh they've
done really well off the back of it and
it's also terrible reviews though that's
the surprising part like the reviews are
awful for it yeah like my both my
editors went to see it thinking that I
was gonna do a video on it
um and then they were like yeah it was
it was crap was the worst thing I've
ever seen you know and they're like but
we did it for the video guys and I'm
like
um yeah did it for the video but we're
working on Mission Impossible first and
yeah it's a movie from the 80s probably
next Indiana so Indiana Jones has
basically had a 56 drop leading to it
now taking
247.9 million worldwide which as you
said could be one of the biggest bombs
of all time
um this is primarily down to the budget
so one of the biggest bombs of all time
for example Pluto Nash it was made for
100 million took in 7 million and I
think we're gonna have to wait until
Indiana Jones finishes its run to see
whether you know it's
as big of a bomb as that percentage-wise
but it's looking pretty bad
um and yet on Independence Day in the US
it was beaten by another film called the
sound of freedom and that was that's a
film about child trafficking quite a
serious subject matter it's not actually
released in the UK
um
I'm sort of getting secondhand
information on it uh but the there's a
lot of things surrounding the film um it
was originally finished in 2018 under
20th Century Fox Disney Then bought the
company uh and they decided to Shell the
film and Jim Caviezel apparently got the
rights back to it and he's distributed
it and it's now beaten Disney so it's
like just a crazy story
um every you know what every time I I
try and read up on it on Twitter or
something there's people arguing back
and forth
um the left and right are going at it
saying it you know it's a right-wing
conspiracy theorist film and then the
left are being sorry the writer being
like well no it's based on true story
and stuff and it's kind of diluted the
conversation around it and but it's
obviously a very important subject
matter I think whatever you think about
where wherever your politics lean I'm
sure you can agree it's very very
important
um and yeah it's kind of it's crazy to
think that the circumstance was that
Disney owned it that they could have
distributed it and now on Independence
Day July 4th was going to be the big day
where everyone was off in America and uh
Indiana Jones was gonna reign supreme
and it's even knocked that off the top
spot
so it kind of takes us into our first
major topic is what has happened with
Disney
I mean Star Wars Marvel and Pixar on our
shelves shells of their former selves
and yeah what are your thoughts on it
Greg
um I'm I'm feeling the same way I feel
about as much as these thumbnails that
we often have and the titles leading in
might look like it's we're raging out in
some way
a lot of the times I hear this and I
find it
I find it a little funny to be honest
it's how like that something is doing
you know like I was just doing a quick
Google search while you were talking and
I I wanted to know and just based off of
the information we currently have in the
trajectory
it's kind of crazy to see how uh Indiana
Jones and the dial of Destiny and I
didn't think this would be the case at
all it is indeed actually looking to be
a a worse box office bomb Than The Flash
movie so to have like two of these
back-to-back movies that in with within
like a one month period like the same
month to be released
is uh it's a bit of a shocker uh to Me
overall and it's just having me think
like do they have this impression
especially Disney do they have this
impression that they can just throw as
much money as they want at something and
not think about any of the repercussions
I could possibly happen when you're
putting this much money into something
then I'm surprised Insidious like
because I don't remember the last one
doing that well and I I haven't seen the
live only seen the first three Insidious
movies I don't remember the fourth one
doing that well maybe there was some
actual hype due the fact that you have
the the cast returning but I thought the
bad reviews and like the the the
lukewarm
um audience reception would not do it
any favors but apparently that fan base
is just that strong to return for
insidious and I'm not surprised like I
haven't even seen a trailer for The
Sound of freedom but the second I heard
faith-based movie I'm like okay that
makes sense because faith-based movies
are always doing really well there
there's something that we I never
personally cover the last faith-based
movie I saw was the Mark Wahlberg Mel
Gibson movie father Stu watched it
randomly on Netflix I actually really
enjoyed it and that's kind of like an
odd ball for a faith-based movie but
that didn't do that that was like a hard
R of a film but anytime I hear of a
faith-based movie the the the the the I
don't know how well you you follow those
but they constantly are in like the top
three and end up making like really good
money every time so I'm not surprised
how well it did what is surprising is
what you're bringing up that it's Fourth
of July
um it Indiana Jones is like an American
icon in cinematic history they wanted to
capitalize specifically off of this and
the fact of how they
didn't really deliver with a movie that
was ultimately special enough I mean I
know it's special to some people and
like I don't if you find it special I'm
happy for you if you did find the
experience overall special but clearly
the word of mouth on this movie
just if the word if if this movie
overall was received more special it
would have it would have had a better
word of mouth and more people would have
gone and seen it that's just a plain and
simple truth like they had a whole
weekend like Fourth of July fell on a
freaking Tuesday so they had like
several days to to just sweep you know
like to be like phenomenal and really
Garner this Amazing Word of Mouth uh but
bottom line it didn't it didn't and you
know Disney's always getting like this
bad press now like for everything from
like Kathleen Kennedy with lucasfilm to
the way animators are treated you know
like and I know that's kind of like an
industry a lot of this is just industry
issues not just Disney solely but Disney
being the the the
um the global masterminds that they are
the face of it all like it makes sense
why a lot of the the blame and Spotlight
would be put on them for what's
happening another question we are going
to talk about Mission Impossible 7 soon
um which has an insanely High budget as
well and part of that insanely High
budget is due to what Indiana Jones had
to suffer with as well with the with
having a film during the pandemic so
it's I'm curious to see if Mission
Impossible 7 will be able to ultimately
profit and outperform as well and and be
like a big box office sensation I think
it will genuinely
um it's open on a Monday in the UK so we
guys we've got it two days ago I think
it's Wednesday for you but even then
that's an early opening and so it's got
a long time to build the money before
the opening weekend and it can come out
to a big Fanfare and be like look how
well it's done and I genuinely think
we'll get into it in a bit but I really
enjoyed the movie and I think it's gonna
have good word of mouth it's we talked
about this last week it's one of those
films where it's like you have to see it
in a cinema and watching it in IMAX I
was blown away by it and I had a feeling
where I was like if I was watching this
at home I don't think it would be as you
know big and crazy but on the on the big
screen the sound honestly it's so
immersive they have bits where there's
no dialogue or sound effects in it it's
just a Scorpio laying over the top and
even though action's happening the sound
effects just aren't there and it's just
the score
um and to have that booming out the the
speakers was crazy um and it just feels
like an experience that you need to go
see in the cinema now
do you think the run time will affect
the bar I mean I know we're gonna do
like a talk on the review Mission
Impossible seven but I feel like since
we're on the box the production budget
and box office subject do you think the
run time because that movie's really
long it's two hours and 40. so is
Indiana Jones is it not about the same
length is that yeah I think Anna Jones
is the same length roughly yeah so I
think it's going to be if they're going
to cancel each other out and if people
are going to go at the cinema and
they're both two hour and 40 minute long
movies I don't think it's gonna affect
it either way um but Insidious is
obviously being sold is a big success
story it has made 32.6 million which if
it was any other movie that wouldn't be
a massive success story but because
they've not spent the the amount that
they should have so you're not spent a
crazy amount like they did with Indiana
Jones which was 300 million plus budget
it's not going to be a loss for the
company and it's going to make their
money and one of the things I feel with
Disney is that greed has destroyed their
branding
um you've got so like I went for a run
last night Greg and I had a bit of an
epiphany and I'm gonna tell you guys
what happened so my headphones run out
of batteries so I had to think for
myself for once
um and I've been thinking you know if
you've been following the channel we had
a really big year last year
um and I I have basically I have a
spreadsheet where I write down all my
views for the month and then a year on
year I can compare them now compared to
last year
stuff's not where it was you know the
views are aren't as big as they were and
it was hitting a point where I was
getting really down about it and what I
started to do was do more videos than I
should because I was just desperate to
get back and to be honest I was being
greedy
um but then I started to think the
person last year if they knew they would
be envious of where I am now
um just because of you know a moved
house I've got staff that are consider
friends and the Channel's in a really
good place you know it might not be
doing the views but we're far more
comfortable than we were we're not
panicking all the time I've got a lovely
family lovely little dog lovely wife
um and I think like you didn't mention
me at all in this in this no you're not
included this the whole list you didn't
once go and I got I got my American
friend Greg you know not not one Not
Another Part of You does everyone just
throw me in there okay no got no friends
in America which is also one of the
great thing and but I was thinking I'm
getting jealous of my past self and the
views that they had
and I know my past self would have been
jealous of where I am now you know what
I mean
um and it would have been looking at me
going oh I could get to that and I know
you have the same thing where it's like
in your head when you have a bad month
you're like oh I could only get to where
I was in the good old days when I was
getting one million more views than what
I'm getting now and I think this and it
just made me realize that
what's enough and is greed slowly
destroying everything when I could be
enjoying it and you know thank God my
had this crazy Epiphany and my
headphones ran out of batteries but I
started thinking you know I could be
greedy right now and want more and more
and more and just keep desperately want
to be like oh I need I want more views
and to think back when I was getting
those views I wouldn't actually say I
was happier than I am now now if you
translate that over to a film studio
it's clear that Disney have seen the
success of what their brands are for
example you know Star Wars was a massive
Thing Marvel was massive Pixar was
massive at one time Pixar is one of
those Studios that they were making
animated movies but not only were they
popular and they made muddly they made
money but they were also really well
critically acclaimed as well as
something that critics could be like oh
Pixar movies that's amazing and what
they've done is they try to be as greedy
as possible they've made so many Disney
plush shows just just pump them out
doesn't matter about what the quality is
just people are going to lap this stuff
up anyway we need to make as much money
as we can and you can see how the greed
of wanting to make more money off the
back of these properties rather than
putting out good things that they're
proud of has just destroyed the brands
almost like you don't hear these things
talked about in the same high esteem
that they used to be oh sure you know
people can enjoy the shows but even
something like secret Invasion I really
enjoy it but I go on Twitter and people
aren't really talking about it no one's
that interested and it just feels like
they they've put out these things over
and over and it has just killed a brand
and it was a long run Greg and I was
thinking you know do you remember back a
couple of years ago there was that
argument they should have ended the MCU
after end game now I love the MCU happy
to keep it going but I was thinking you
know what maybe they should have just
taken some time off and a break because
even thinking of how it was structured
like the first film in the the timelines
Captain America the First Avenger ends
with Captain America not getting to
dance with Peggy Carter and then getting
froze in a nice final shot of end game
is Captain America dancing with Peggy
car and I was thinking imagine if they
just step back at that point
how highly recorded the series would be
it would be like whoa they ended it
perfectly and maybe took some time off
but instead what they did was they
doubled down and were like well we've
got a Golden Goose here let's just crap
out as many eggs as we can and you can
see like they didn't need to make an
Indiana Jones 5 and the greed of wanting
to
get Harrison Ford back out get that
money in we need fans to do it and it
was the same thing when they announced
Toy Story that the next Toy Story movie
I don't even know what number it is now
but they've announced another Toy Story
movie and stuff and it's just kind of
like
yeah Toy Story five and I'm just
thinking you're making these decisions
based off greed and not because you
actually want to do it you're just
constantly wanting more and more money
and you're pushing out as many products
as possible and you don't realize that
in the end it's gonna bring it all
crashing down yeah because people are
just sick of the the mediocrity right
now even when you make something good
like secret invasion in my opinion uh
people just aren't interested anymore I
think that
I think you're right absolutely I think
you're right and I think that the greed
has always been there
obviously they're
they're Mega corporation on all fronts
um so greed has always been there and a
lot of the times you know you can look
at a lot of the decision making and go
well that's business right that is
definitely business of okay how do we
save costs to maximize profit you know
like I I totally get that I I sincerely
do
I think right now what's happening and
especially in the last couple years is
while the greed has always been there
you've always kind of had to have a line
of how do we be like it's going to sound
a little messed up but yeah how do we be
greedy but at the same time not really
let the world feel the greed and now
we're feeling the degree now now the
greed I think is just more apparent than
ever like you could always you could
always look into [__] and like if
they've been franchising stuff out
forever they make stuff just for toys
there's always been a billion different
things that that companies like Disney
will do that are solely based and not in
reverancy for this storytelling or
whatever it is it has been totally to
make money like most of the decision
Studios will make movies and shows to
make a profit to make money so sometimes
like it's just a business decision that
doesn't necessarily equate to being
greedy at the same time I'd get the
analogy that you're making from you know
being YouTubers to now because we know
the feeling of when something is doing
well for us like how do we milk it and
then uh okay things are going bad how do
we just do more volume then to
compensate for the lack of views like I
I totally get where you're uh you're
coming from there and I I full heartily
agree and I think just now what's
happening with Disney is in particular
as you can see from when they bought
Star Wars and and how they monopolize
their properties is they just keep
shelving [__] out without thinking about
reception and how and the and the
importance of quality because there is
value in missing something there is
value and then if you a big part of what
I think sells whether it be tuning into
a show or tuning into a movie like I
think why like a big thing that I'll do
on my Channel or trailer reactions right
and a lot of times what you do are
trailer breakdowns and why I think those
do so well is because you get this
feeling of anticipation and if you don't
give us time to miss something that
feeling of anticipation becomes weaker
it's nowhere near as strong as it needs
to be so yeah like they just kind of put
their foot on the pedal at full speed uh
with a lot of these things particularly
with Star Wars and Marvel and instead of
allowing us to miss stuff and bring
quality because that's part of my
concern with Deadpool three uh yeah it's
happening right now is I'm excited for
Deadpool 3 like I see these costumes I
know who's in it I mean like it's like
at least what's officially revealed who
knows what leaks are true and what
aren't
I'm excited for Deadpool 3 but they're
shooting this in the middle of a rider
strike and as much Faith as I have and
this is a Disney movie this is this is
like a Disney move like they made a
weird move to me
um where they're like we're gonna
release this earlier actually while
we're filming this in a writer's like
wait what I I think you this is
something that if they need to delay it
to make it a better movie they really
should delay it to make it a better
movie because of the hype that they have
built into it right now like obviously
you can have a really good script in
pre-production and have some good ideas
but any filmmaker will tell you that
when you come when it comes time to
being on set and shooting something not
everything is going to go according to
plan out everything's gonna turn out the
way you you envisioned it to be
sometimes you get happy accidents
sometimes you get [__] where you're like
this just isn't working and they're in a
position where they can't rewrite
anything they can't change anything they
have to work with what they got hot and
when you remove that opportunity that
when you remove that option to be able
to change stuff which is such a
necessary ingredient to making a good
movie
then you get a diminished property and
the fact that they're like move Disney's
moving this up
like the one can go that must mean they
have a lot of faith in what it is
another can be exactly what your initial
Point actually is Paul is that they see
the hype for this they see what's
happening with Marvel they need
something with that is going to like
rebound and regain and get them a
billion dollar hit uh Deadpool release
it sooner get it done get it out there
like but we're in the writer strike
shouldn't we make a better movie and
wait no just get it out like there's two
conversations that could be had with it
so yeah I I'm with you that greed has
always been there obviously it's just
it's just now coming to the surface a
lot more apparent now
yeah I was yeah I just think greed
destroys everything I've literally sat
and thought about it last night so much
relationships you know people end up
cheating on their partners because they
just see someone else that they like and
then they cheat with them and realize I
shouldn't have done that I've ruined my
life and yeah just just I was literally
thinking it's the worst human trait last
night and uh yeah powered through their
own got got 10K done in an hour so happy
with myself but tell you what Greg going
back to that point of franchising stuff
out there is ways to do it and I think
when people care it just comes across
Mission Impossible seven you know where
seven films deep now it could be seen as
a greedy thing potentially I don't feel
that at all with this film I think you
can tell you know even down to the
delays they move this movie back a
couple of times because they wanted you
know people to they wanted time to
finish it and for p if basically it'd be
the best thing it could be and one thing
I feel about Tom Cruise
I feel like he's putting his all into
these films I really really do
everything the guy um just the way
promotes it you can tell that he's
grateful that people are going to watch
his film as well it just he's not like
oh yeah here's another one we just put
it out yeah uh we did we just did this
whatever even when he's in interviews
he's like he's thanking people for
coming to see his movie and stuff and
it's like no I enjoy watching them Tom
yeah and let's get into our sort of
spoilery review of Mission Impossible
dead reckoning now I think I'm gonna
have a slightly different reaction to
you
not massively but
hit it off Greg what what were your
thoughts on it
I like the thing is I like Mission
Impossible 7. I I absolutely
first off on the Tom Cruise thing I just
want to tell you yeah like uh I could
talk about Tom Cruise I could do we
could do a whole podcast just about Tom
Cruise's work ethic is I mean there's a
reason he delayed top gun Maverick and
he would refuse to let it release at a
certain time because there's one
producer out there who I sincerely
believe cares about the audience
um reception and really cares about the
audience experience it's Tom Cruise like
he can repeat the same answers in a
billion interviews and it seems like
he's answering it for the first time
because he cares that much about
qualitative promote like he he really
gives a [__] so and that shows in this
movie I did not see this on IMAX it was
uh and I know that that is the way to
see this movie so I have tickets to see
it again I'm looking forward to seeing
it again and I love Mission Impossible
three through six love those movies so
much and I would say I like this one
quite a bit I liked it a lot there were
just aspects to it that just did not and
I know some people are like you should
just kind of take it on its own merits
and I'm like well it's part seven and
it's a movie that really also definitely
encompasses the a lot that came before
it that requires viewing of the previous
I can't just look at it it's a
standalone like you're asking me to
complete that's a weird thing to ask of
a viewer to go seven movies in and just
completely negate the other ones like I
can't that's you can't do that that's
that's a it's like a massive brain trick
I gotta pull on myself
um because it has all the ingredients
that I like about all the Mission
Impossible movies uh for sure and you
know the big stunts uh the a lot of the
cool plot lines Tom Cruise is uh more
than committed performance
I just wasn't as enveloped in the actual
some people just go to these movies now
only for the payoff of the stunts and
stuff like that and in the action scenes
and for me I've always really loved the
things surrounding the action scenes and
that was the part where I thought some
of the pacing and the tone and the
quality of the writing around those
elements outside of the action scenes
and I would not say like not all of it
wasn't working for me it's just there
were there's too many moments throughout
that were kind of not really hitting it
for me that kind of would undermine
feelings where I thought could have been
more intense or exciting and I know we
said semi-spoilery so I'm going to
really mince my words here spoilers it's
the heavy spoilers show Even though uh
even though it's not out okay fine
um
there's something that really England
okay all right all right well heavy
spoilers here there's something that
really bothered me in this movie that I
didn't even tease in my non-spoiler
review
Rebecca Ferguson dies in this movie
and that should have been the thing that
I thought would have been like okay I
guess it's about to get real dark and
personal
and they they get like a moment of Tom
Cruise looking sad
for like a couple minutes and then you
kind of just forget about it
well now yeah that's what I mean I was
like what this is this is like the girl
who's been in the last three movies like
this the one who might have been the
potential new love of his life and then
even here they're getting more intimate
at times like they're holding hands and
[__] and
um and then I've even talked with a
couple people who saw it a couple weeks
ago and I brought up like
and then you know from the bottom is
like how Rebecca Ferguson dies and then
they don't even really treat it that
like and then the same reaction would
come from almost everyone which is oh
yeah I forgot about that like people
forget that she died and I'm like and
that's not a good sign to me about it
um and and like I don't know when I
watch like three through six
especially like three and six those a
lot of those scenes really hit for me
you know like the the feels really kick
in for me um and so yeah it was it was
kind of like
there has a lot of the plot stuff seems
to be doing exactly it's even right down
to they've gone Rogue you've got people
chasing Ethan Hunt the ai's gun Rogue
hey it's gone Rogue our team's gone
Rogue you got these people who are
hunting Ethan Hunt again and it's like
it's a weird plot point to me by this
point because I'm like how come every
time these people who are hunting Ethan
Hunt they're always treating him like
he's the worst Terrorist on the whole
goddamn Planet I'm like you're you're
you're the seventh movie to be doing
this stuff like you're the worst people
on the goddamn Planet when there's never
anyone to be like you know maybe he's
just being framed again or maybe he's
just misunderstood again
and yeah when the train who said that
eventually yeah eventually no maybe
um and I think what happens is I'm so
well aware of of like it's got like a 99
of rotten tomatoes and I see most people
are like highlight in the air because
like yeah the thing you show up for from
the trailers it's all great all that's
great yeah don't get me wrong it's great
um but to me most of this movie is um is
not action as as rightfully should be
most of it's not action and and it's
that stuff that wasn't quite singing as
high for me like I thought the whole
thing with the villain having this
personal backstory felt a little bit
forced and not naturally weaved in I
felt like I could really feel like we
need to figure out a way to do it so and
I think I kind of over explain the
things that weren't really quite working
for me because I'm so well aware of how
how how loved it is that I I over
explained the things that didn't work
for me when I'm like well the things
that most people love I'm actually in
agreeance with you on like Tom Cruise is
great I love Palm Clementi if in it I
love Haley Atwell Sensational action
scenes are really good even the parts of
the action that were not fully working
for me I do think though on a second
viewing I will like it more and I think
especially watching it on real IMAX I'm
probably gonna end up I'm my I might
graduate to the love level for it but
right now I'm just like no I liked it a
lot I did I liked it a lot I would put
it below the last four but I still liked
it a lot
yeah um yeah back to the Elsa thing I do
agree that I've written my review and
recorded it and that was one of the
points I brought up I feel that was
slightly lessened by the fact they had a
fake out death of her at the start of
the movie
so it was kind of like oh I've already
gone through experiencing her death and
then it happened again
um yeah I do think they could have
dealt with that moment a bit more it
kind of felt like maybe she'd just been
written out or they didn't find it that
interesting or she had scheduling
conflicts but Ethan didn't really seem
to hang on it my other issue with the
film was just the constant agencies and
or I lost at some points who he was
actually working for and uh yeah I just
didn't fully get the villain motivation
which is a good thing that I'm making
and then explain tomorrow going overall
but I do kind of get it but I thought
the villain was a bit weak and obviously
if you're in the spoiler section
um it's basically an AI who's kind of
infiltrated every aspect of life and
they want to take over and they can
basically control the truth
um and spread misinformation to either
cause Wars or end them or Empower
certain people and there's a guy working
for them called Gabriel who ties back to
Ian's past he killed a woman in his past
um and yeah he's kind of uh sort of not
a massive I don't know I don't get the
personality leaping off him
um so yeah I did I felt like he felt
flat but
I love the film
um I really really enjoyed it I thought
the action was really good and even when
the the action wasn't happening I I felt
they shot the
the sort of the exposition heavy scenes
really well there's a moment where they
have like seven different actors
um sitting in a room each one's
delivering a different line of dialogue
yeah yeah a guy like walks in looking
mysterious in the corner and stuff and
they shoot it in a way that it's
interesting to watch
um even if it is kind of just very
Exposition heavy and someone explaining
the plot and you and you can feel the
hands of the writer being like right
we've written out what needs to be said
how do we make this look interesting
well we'll give the line to seven
different people or whatever
um but I love the way that the film
ramps up
um you start off with a submarine very
intense and then you you cut to like a
delivery guy dropping off a parcel and
Ethan on six standing in the corner in
the darkness out of the way like the
Riddler or something uh and then they go
to the airport which is a really good
scene
um and it's all sort of just people
walking around grabbing each other yeah
it's done in such a way that it's very
enthralling and you get introduced to
Hayley Atwell she's kind of a Catwoman
sort of figure uh very interesting
though you know I love I could sing
Hayley atwell's praises to death uh she
really stood up with me she's sort of
you know when people say like the go off
on their runs about woke strong female
characters and stuff hell yeah well in
this film I can't see how he could ever
find fault with her I think she does
vulnerable really well she's just strong
she's witty uh cunning she can handle
this off in an action scene I think she
does really really well with it so don't
you dare come to this Podcast chat about
walk soon I I think I mean to just
quickly interject about that point I I
think I think Haley apple is an absolute
breath I loved her here and I think like
the mission impossible franchise Lately
from Palm to Rebecca Ferguson
um to uh to Haley Atwell I I think they
do an excellent job at female a strong
female characters I think they do a
wonderful job I don't ever hear people
even say the word like woke around
um around them I think they're all good
yeah they are they're really good
um so yeah thought thought they were
brilliant and the stunts as well uh just
to have the train scene at the end so
well put together with all the masks and
stuff and then they keep elevating it
and having different things you've got
sort of people sitting down talking but
whilst that's going on Tom Cruise is on
a motorbike riding along good and you
said right last week that the uh the
cliff scene was very short but I thought
it was quite long because you have them
going off the cliff and then you follow
them for a while and then he does his
parachute and stuff and then swings into
the train so yeah I really enjoyed that
and I was thinking I don't know what the
hell Greg's talking about he's a
disgrace thumbs down I was getting my
phone out and gone on the video and
thumbs down in it
um and then once the train jumps off the
cliff it's over once he's off the cliff
it's open no but if you follow him down
and he's like oh [__] yeah eventually
where he's parachuting yeah there's
eventually yeah and then you have a
fight on top of the train which is great
and then the train goes off the edge and
they've got to climb up it just thought
really well thought our action scene
strangely it's very similar to Indiana
Jones on a number of levels sure you've
got a you've got a spicy British
brunette sidekick getting herself in
trouble
you've got two half of a McGuffin that
need to come together you've got a train
sequence where the the train gets uh did
the train go off the edge at the start
of Indiana Jones I don't remember yeah
he had eventually uh falls off that's
they have to jump because it's gonna
fall
lots of similar things yeah but I
thought this just kept the adrenaline up
the pace was incredible
um even for a long movie you know I did
feel it at times but they were
constantly reinvent like Reinventing
what was happening and you know just in
the same way I said this in my John Wick
review I feel like you can tell the
people behind the film have
you know they basically made this film a
number of times like John Wick that
they'd made the same sort of film
several times and the the latest film
was them sort of
be showing off that they've now mastered
all of these elements so like your car
chases your gun fights your action
scenes everything's down pat and I feel
like this is what that film is it's
everything they've kind of learned
whilst they were making all the other
movies they brought that together and
it's just a master class in how to make
an action movie Tom Cruise the guy Blow
Me Away
um and yeah I just loved it I really did
uh the score was incredible you know
it's massive in scale it's a worldwide
Truck Adventure and they didn't even
lean that heavily like in the gadgets in
this one you know normally you'll get
something creative where they make
themselves invisible going down a
hallway or they'll do something with one
of the gadgets will mess up and they've
got to improvise around it and they
didn't do it that much in this film it
was more kind of physical stuff which I
thought worked really well like fair
enough they had the the face swapping
stuff in the airport
but it wasn't like to the level that
they normally do it
but yeah I loved it do you missed some
of this I do I kind of miss a little bit
of the
I thought that okay with getting I
forget the character's name but the guy
from mission impossible one who comes
back here
um
no no no no no the white guy the the one
who's like is he bad or good get rich
kid rich yeah yeah
um I thought they might go back a little
bit more because I noticed
tonally they were I felt like McCrory
was aiming to tonally have a little bit
of that
Menace that Brian De Palma brought to
the first one
um in terms of like the Espionage Menace
but the movie itself doesn't ever really
become like an Espionage film it's more
this to me is more of a straightforward
like action thriller than than the
previous ones there's less spot I mean I
don't know maybe Fallout is too uh but
yeah I I'm kind of missing a little bit
more of like some of the spy stuff I
mean it's there uh like the hacking the
satellites whenever you got Benji and
Luther uh especially like at the airport
scene felt the most akin to some of the
things I've been I was I've been wanting
from the movies again uh like I really
like that airport scene a lot might not
be like crazy stunts or anything like
that but I love the way that whole scene
is crafted together like it's it's
intense it's gripping it ramps up really
well
and I did the the thing with the the
train sequence oh do you know what two
two
um
[__] Vanessa Kirby uh I think it's so
good at this she's so good she has this
part in the movie
where
like when she's just playing whatever
the character I forget the character's
name do you remember the character's
name I don't remember her name um Elena
the buyer uh but when she's just being
her daughter yeah yeah when she's being
herself
um her actual character like she's good
but I loved how she played she had to be
Hayley Atwell pretending to be her yeah
and be Haley I mean she's so good in
that a long scene oh yeah she's amazing
there
um
I thought her performance was excellent
the the train sequence I love the
craftsmanship of it and I love the
choreo the literally the whole thing is
choreographed together
the part the one part of it that was a
bit distracting to me and that's only
because I've like with the Mission
Impossible movies I'm obsessed with the
behind there's not many movies where I'm
obsessed with the behind the scenes of
them on and Mission Impossible in
particular I am very much obsessed with
the behind the scenes and that might
have been something that actually worked
against me for the motorcycle stunt
because that motorcycle stunt I thought
was so effective in the behind the
scenes and the one thing I was saying
and my review was that I feel like with
a lot of the big stunts in these films
that you usually get like a full scene
where it's so suspenseful and I did feel
like when he's off the cliff like you
you kind of cut back to the parachute
and and I wasn't a fan of how they ended
it where he just um where it ends on a
joke where it's just like he he crashes
through and and conveniently saves Haley
Atwell on the train like I I wish there
was like some kind of like actual seeing
him go to the train I know it's a lot to
ask of someone like I wish Tom Cruise
was really risking his life so much and
like [__] parachuted like I wish I
saw that that's a lot to ask
um and so I thought it was so
short-lived and and that we didn't get
much of a dramatic tension scene out of
it the more the drama and the tension of
it was him like going up the hill on the
motorcycle
um but not really the stunt in and of
itself but it's still a wildly
impressive stun I don't want that to be
like I want that I really want that to
be underscored like it's a wildly
impressive stun but in the train
sequence when when everything when
they're like hopping around it really
reminded me of Uncharted yeah Uncharted
too especially specifically the opening
of that game and
it the part that was only distracting me
and that's only because I'm so obsessed
with the behind the scenes so I kind of
think it it it it uh it works against me
having some of this awareness but I
can't tell if it just looks this way or
if it actually is the case because of
the way like when they're hanging and
stuff that I just and the fact that
Haley atwell's there and the things are
collapsing that it looked like a green
screen to me
um on the train when everything is like
when like you know the sequence of the
piano is going to crash on them and so
to me it actually pulled me out of the
suspense and the danger uh only because
I was like um I'm kind of aware that
this isn't real
um and it's kind of like the way I felt
about Ghost Protocol with the parking
garage scene at the end like this is a
little too much for me yeah I think with
Mission Impossible movies is that they
do so much of it practically
to the point that when they do something
with CGI you can spot it and I did
notice that about the train I was
obviously you know they're not going to
dangle well they might dangle Tom Cruise
but not Haley yeah yeah I've seen the
biplane scenes coming up in the the next
film
um but yeah I felt you know going back
to that first film uh which you brought
before this was them remaking the third
act from the first film and I mean it's
got kit Rich involved it's got Max's
daughter it's them redoing it now
knowing everything that they know about
yeah uh filming and how to make action
scenes and yeah
um it ended on a bit of a weird
Cliffhanger it wasn't really
I don't know it kind of felt like it
could keep going I know it's a part one
um but it was cut I I personally like
Cliffhangers that feel like losses
almost
um for example Infinity War Empire
Strikes Back that sort of thing and
whereas this he gets the key the two
keys at the end it's like you're now
going after the Sebastopol and did they
ever explain what was actually on the
the submarine because they kept going
when it unlocks you gotta you find out
the truth of what's really in there and
uh
in French
and my wife leaned over and said what
they saying and I was like I I don't
know and I missed it all and I was
thinking bloody hell I've gotta make a
video on this tomorrow and I've got no
idea what they just said and they're
speaking in French and there's no
subtitles uh so yeah did the did they
mention about the uh the thing in the
Box
I'm not sure my favorite part about the
writing in the first 20 minutes
was how like every scene
[Music]
you call it an epic but I I think it's I
thought it was funny of how every scene
they just had to re-explain
there's a key all right and then you got
to get the other half of this key and
you gotta put the keys together to
control and like every scene just kept
reestablishing this and I'm like I get
the [__] point about the keys like
that we don't can you just cut to like
the middle of the scene where they've
already learned about the key and then
that's my own so I got so focused on the
McGuffin that I was like oh I'm not even
thinking about what the what the actual
thing is history boxes
um but yeah it's a good movie though
it's a fun it's a fun movie and
brilliant it's fun I I I I feel like on
a second viewing especially on IMAX uh
because I went to one of these like um
you know events on Paramount lot and I'm
surprised that they they showed it on
Dolby which is a great screen and great
sound uh but this movie's obviously
meant for IMAX and like I've like I'm
not a Ghost Protocol Rogue Nation
Fallout first times I saw those movies
were on IMAX and they shoot these with
IMAX cameras the way it's meant to be
seamless so like when you when you craft
a movie specifically for that format
that that's the old like I've seen some
Nolan movies where I saw it on a regular
screen I thought they were okay and then
I watched them on an iMac so I'm like oh
wait I actually get this movie much more
and I'm kind of wondering if I sort of
feeling like I'm gonna get that I know
not everyone who's seen this movie who
loves it saw it on IMAX I'm fully aware
of that I'm wondering for me though as
someone who often has that like
filmmaker awareness just because I love
the behind the scenes and it makes me
understand the vision and intent much
better uh that when I watch it on iMac
some I'm gonna be like okay yeah no this
now it's really it's really clicked with
me this time so yeah yeah I know it's I
I think and regardless I think it is one
of those movies more than Indiana Jones
that warrants a big screen viewing this
this requires like when Tom Cruise says
he makes movies for the big screen he
really means it and and in a day and age
where everything gets kind of washed out
by massive amounts of CGI and you could
do crazy CGI on television now but you
can't really do crazy practical big
stunts and that's one of the things that
makes John Wick special as well the the
leg up that I feel John Wick 4 has over
this is that to me the story of John
Wick 4 did something different enough
with their story with like where the
Ensemble and the new characters really
shine and we're such a takeaway with the
storytelling whereas here a lot of the
story telling feels like yeah these are
the Beats of a mission impossible movie
these are the this is the outline of a
mission impossible movie for the most
part
um but still the the sets pieces the
action scenes the locations like one
thing I loved with that in the in the
car chase with the Fiat is did you
actually I forget did you have
um someone else do the fast X Breakdown
or did you do that yeah I don't remember
I did it yeah okay the the scene in in
Rome when they're going down the stairs
and like they're doing a lot of the same
locations in fast X but he like the the
exact same locations uh but here you get
to see it done practically with these
like brilliant locked off shots where
you they got the cameras mounted on the
cars and I thought it was so cool to
like I just saw fast sex a couple weeks
ago now I'm watching this where fast X
and while like there's like you could
take the God's eye thing and put it to
the AI thing here and uh so there's
similarities you can certainly draw
um but in terms of vid like I would much
rather see this on the big screen for
the action scenes that I would see fast
X because of just how much the Practical
side of it really does shine and I also
love the story of this one how it's so
much about Ethan Hunt and the women in
his life like so women love Ethan Hunt
so much man he is a protector
so yeah man I still I still liked it a
lot I still did I don't want people to
think I didn't like it a lot
I said in my review it's like Fast and
the Furious if Fast and the Furious
wasn't [__] uh yeah that's how I feel
about the film it's got family
um I actually prefer over John Wick
purely because of the characters I think
John Wick is a little flat on the
characterization of characters you know
they don't really have that much depth
they're sort of two-dimensional people
who are like I will kill John Wick why
are you doing that
ears are not honorable he has brought
shame and stuff like that you know what
I mean whereas yeah I mean Hayley
atwell's character I can totally
understand even Benji just panicking try
and disarm a bomb stuff like that you
know I think that goes further for me at
least
um but I mean they're both great films
and you know this year has been really
good for action movies I think
uh so yeah but I think this is gonna be
the runaway hit of the year to be honest
you know Barbie and Oppenheimer might do
well but
I think either this or Mario is probably
gonna come out on top so yeah very good
that's the part of it though that I'm
that I'm wondering is that because you
got Barbie and Oppenheimer a one week
after this you know and lifespan on the
same day thing yeah conversations on
movies die pretty quick so I'm I'm
wondering if like it's just coming out
if the timing of it might not be good
because it's complete it's got two big
movies following it one week later two
movies that are expected to do well at
the box office
top gun Maverick you know that had legs
it was months and months after where it
was still making money and I think Tom
Cruise is going to keep it in the cinema
it's not going to be something that's
dumped on streaming in 45 days time I
think they're going to keep it and it'll
keep making money
got even more hype now oh that trailer
was shown in IMAX before it was the
first time I've seen it in IMAX
it's crazy to step up like watching it
on a laptop screen or even on like I've
got a 60-inch uh OLED
but watching it in the cinema
blew me away absolutely amazing
um trying to pull up the thing I sent
you yesterday of on on hologram is that
the
um in order for
because it was like a percent I was
looking up a percentage breakdown of
like how much did Fallout make based off
of its budget so in order for it to
match the same profit percentage because
some people were saying that it's every
every Outlet I know some people are like
in our in our comments in the last video
were saying that no this had to be for
two movies uh the 290 million the budget
yeah but they didn't shoot uh seven and
eight back to back so the report on
every Outlet is reporting part one as
290 million and a big factor of that is
is the fact that they shot it during
covid and they had to shut the movie
down like seven times
um and but they still have to keep
people like you know paid staying in the
countries that they were filming it like
it cost them a lot of extra money to
shoot this during covid
um so it was like 209 million so but if
to make the same profit percentage
of of success it would need to make like
1.64 billion dollars just based off of
the inflated budget that this movie get
does now it doesn't need to make that to
be considered a success
um because the budget's 290 million and
in fact if it matches Fallout it'll be
fine Fallout made like 800 million
dollars uh so the question is like I
think I think it has a good chance of
you know the fact that he just did Top
Gun Maverick and that was his first
billion dollar hit and I think he has
that like Good Will with audiences that
you know he'll deliver uh he'll deliver
the goods on that but but I think the
top gun Maverick I don't think this will
reach
um I don't think it'll be as big as top
gun Maverick there was more hope for top
gun Maverick because of like finally
he's doing it and then it's more of a
rousing tighter More feel-good film by
the you know like that's more to me is
as much as he delivers on stunts and all
that excitement you know like I prefer
this kind of I prefer the mission
impossible franchise Over the Top Gun
franchise I it to me it just makes a lot
more sense top gun Maverick would be
like this is the more repeat viewing
experience this is the one where like
you get crowds from like I remember when
I saw top gun Maverick I was like wow
there's like a bunch of 50 year olds
here you know there's like a a much
older audience that's here as well as a
younger audience uh and I I feel like
that's what it has more of a leg up on
that Amazon shorter movie so yeah I
prefer topical Maverick but I like
that's one of my favorite films
um but you know this is a part one as
well so it's laying the groundwork for
part two sure so if it does well I mean
even if it just breaks even it but if it
builds enough Goodwill that people are
desperate to see that second movie like
one of the reasons why Avengers end game
was so big was because Avengers Infinity
war was so big you know what I mean it
was so good that I got people hyped for
that next film and I feel like this
could do it maybe not to that level but
I definitely feel like there's a lot of
good things going on with it and it
could pave the way for them I mean they
were originally talking about that being
the last mission Impossible film but
they've now said no we've got more ideas
we're gonna have them go Rogue
um so yeah lots of good things there and
Vanessa Kirby might be seeing her again
very soon as we move on to our next
topic what is it correct
oh we're gonna do it the Fantastic Four
one we're doing it we didn't talk about
it
all right I guess we'll talk about it
well looks like
um the converse when it comes to the
leaks on fantastic form going off memory
here when it comes to the leaks of
Fantastic Four
of who the casting is for a while it was
like looks like it's going to be Adam
Driver Margot Robbie uh and then now
it's looking like it might not be looks
like they might have backed out and
instead of seeing other reports saying
that it is going to be Adam Driver still
but who knows who knows who knows we'd
look
um but now it seems that Margot Robbie
being out that Vanessa Kirby might just
be taking her place uh to be the next
Zoo storm which I am all for that
casting in fact I actually prefer I I
love Mark I don't want anyone to think
like she's one of my favorite actresses
working today I love the hell out of
Margot Robbie part of me though is like
I actually prefer the casting of Vanessa
Kirby just because she's not at the same
height of Margot Robbie in terms of of
Fame and stuff and I think it would be
cool for her to get that opportunity to
be like the true like one of the main
stars of this film like I love her work
in the mission of Possible movies I even
really liked her work in uh the much
forgotten Hobbs and Shaw film I thought
she was great in that and I've always
every time she shows up anywhere I think
she knows how to command the screen when
she's there and so I would I would love
for her to be Sue storm I feel like she
can bring um because she could be fun
and she could be intense at the same
time she can do action she could do it
all and I feel like she's deserving of
having like a big starring role where
she is like one of the centerpieces of
it instead of
another female supporting character you
know what I mean uh I think she could be
great
what do you think she would expect her
across I think she works better against
Adam Driver than Margot Robbie does as
well I don't know Margot Robbie kind of
brings a different vibe to Adam Driver
to me whereas I think Vanessa Kirby
could quite easily match that and sort
of tonally work quite well with him and
you know actors have got to have
chemistry and stuff especially these
these are two are like these are
probably the most famous married couple
in comic books outside of maybe Pierre
Parker and Mary Jane but who knows what
if they're married anymore like they
keep changing it every other week yeah
but yeah so I feel Vanessa Kirby matches
Adam Driver if he has indeed got the
role now
speaking of married couples
we also have Elektra who's apparently
going to be in Deadpool 3 and I'm
guessing that this is going to be linked
to the Ben Affleck Cameo now in case you
don't know they used to be married and I
felt for our Ben because I was thinking
like oh you know he's just got a new job
and then all of a sudden his ex-wife
starts working there as well but I'm
sure they get on really well behind the
scenes I have actually heard they're
getting quite well you know he seems
like a mature guy
um so yeah I've heard that you know that
that I'm sure they'll be fine and
that'll be uh that'll be very strange
now Deadpool all the news with that it's
going crazy right now how are you
feeling about it
I mean I mentioned what my concerns were
about it when we were talking about the
production budget but man I'm I'm
excited dude I'm I'm really excited like
when I saw the Wolverine costume I have
a feeling at some point in the movie the
sleeves will be torn off uh the arm
sleeves I think at one point he will
tear them off
um but I still don't mind it like even
when I what really click for me I was
like okay yeah this looks cool but when
I saw the forgetting the specific name
of it on his claws of where there are on
the gloves
for some reason just honing in on that
and knowing like oh the clouds are going
to be protruding from there this time
and seeing them on the gloves themselves
I was like
this is just getting me so excited like
it is working for me on that animated
love level and then when I've read it
from the comics you know because
when we saw Patrick Stewart gonna be in
like Multiverse of Madness and maybe
he's like the X-Men animated series
version but nothing was really done with
that it really weren't a big
conversation
I think this is going to be the exact
kind of opposite effect and then hearing
that it seems like they really are
controlling the narrative behind the
scenes you know like let's show The
Wolverine costume let's show the
Deadpool costume they look more comics
accurate both of the costumes uh the
rumors like letting something like if
you said Ben AFF if they leaked at Ben
Affleck if Holly report a report on Ben
Affleck returning that's like too big
but then saying Elektra that's just
enough to make you go maybe Ben
Affleck's actually returning now too
it's turned on maybe that is yeah so to
put you in that terrain do I think it'll
match because I think the thing is like
with Multiverse of Madness they
The Cameo rumors were just too insane
that it was a point where it was like 30
to 40 cameos being rumored this is
Cruise Line man
yeah do I think that this movie will
have that many cameos no do I think
it'll more than deliver on the cameos
and make it more rewarding than what
Multiverse a Madness did yes I I don't
think it'll ever be as crazy as
Multiverse of Madness the the rumor mill
went but I think it'll ultimately be
satisfying and it's like they're showing
us this stuff it does have me wonder
okay if we see some of the other X-Men
like what if we see uh James Marston in
an accurate Cyclops costume you know
what if we get to see like some cool
[__] like that and then getting to pay
off the fox Universe in a way that could
be fun with saying goodbye to them but
one thing about the Deadpool movies that
I think some people often forget about
is that those both those movies have so
much heart at the end of the day those
movies have a lot of emotion still
rooted in them in the midst of like
really wacky weird comedy and I feel
like it'll it'll be something of a
of a nostalgic goodbye to the fox
Universe while also taking the piss out
of the fox Universe you know uh I I
think they're gonna I think they can
make something really special so
regardless of my worries that I have for
the film of uh while it's in production
I still feel like ultimately it'll give
me some of the some of my favorite
moments of the Deadpool Trilogy even if
it's not my favorite Deadpool movie I
think I'll still get some of my favorite
moments I mean how are you feeling I saw
your I did I did listen to your uh
breakdown last night
um so I know you you got a bunch of
information on it but how are you how
are you feeling though about it dude
yeah you know what when I first heard it
the leaks I was like I think it's it's
kind of a victim of coming out when it
is which is you know we get we've had so
many Multiverse movies now and we kind
of know the tropes of them it's like
bring back all the actors from other
franchises and have some time travel
stuff and someone's gotta die to
sacrifice themselves and stuff like that
and and you know if you can probably
predict the the plot of Deadpool 3 I
mean whether these plot leaks are true
or not you know we don't know but
they do sound a bit cookie cutter now
what is gonna raise them for me is kind
of like I'm a big fox X-Men fan at one
point don't tell anyone I preferred it
to the MCU
um and you know seeing Hubert Jackman
back Ian McKellen
um it's probably spoiling too much
seeing the X-Men characters back is
gonna be good
um and it does sound like it's gonna be
a farewell to that Universe whilst also
maintaining some things that they can
bring across now if you want to know
what the plot the plot is or it might be
then go over to my plot League breakdown
but I don't want to spoil more beyond
that in case because there will be
people who probably annoyed that I've
just said what I've said anyway
um but yeah it sounds sounds crazy it
sounds a bit like a sort of mix between
Loki and
Multiverse of Madness almost but like a
better way to do it yeah I mean they're
gonna you know one of my big worries
about the MCU at the moment has been
like they're not gonna handle incursions
properly
I'll absolutely love Secret Wars and I
think the way they're doing it not to
play my hand too much but it sounds like
if you're aware of that story they're
sort of making the a38 that they're
turning that into the 616 and it's gonna
be sort of uh sorry the Ultimate
Universe sorry and it's going to be a
sort of Ultimate Universe which is the
eight through eight versus the 616 sort
of thing so
how it's gonna play out I don't know I
have heard some things about what
they're going to do after Secret Wars
which I might do in a video but it's
very oh it's obviously incredibly early
days now but
you know
X-Men fans you're gonna be happy and if
you're fans of Avengers versus X-men
you're gonna be happy as well so yeah
lots of uh lots of things to look
forward to
yeah man the costume looks great as well
The Wolverine costume yeah sorry I love
it I love the costume so much I think
it's it's funny because this costume
wouldn't work you know when you look
back at the Wolverine deleted The
Wolverine deleted scene when they showed
you the
like oh he might wear the costume but he
doesn't wear the costume that would have
more of like a almost almost like a
slight orange tint to it which are just
kind of like how some of the comics are
it was like a darker yellow and maybe
that would have worked in the live
action X-Men but if he was like the only
X-Men with a common member with a
costume like that and everyone else was
still like dark leather if it wouldn't
have worked this costume would not have
worked in that X-Men franchise but the
fact that they have this in the Deadpool
movie and bring it into the MCU it does
work yeah and Tim for me as a as someone
who's been wanting like a more
Wolverine accurate costume to hearken
back to the comics
um I've always been saying like many
other people that if you're going to
bring him over here I feel like the last
remaining payoff you really need for
Hugh Jackman
Beyond like joining The Avengers or some
[__] is give him a more comics accurate
costume and
I think that's what it was about
specifically of where the claws are
going to be coming out of because you
know like that was such a big moment in
the first X-Men movie of when it comes
out between his knuckles and you know
the people was like no it's supposed to
come up from like up here and like oh
they're even changing that up so so this
really is showing you like this is going
to be a different this is going to be a
different Wolverine
um to me that's such an indicator of it
more than a costume that this will be a
different Wolverine because that where
the claws come from was such a big thing
in those X-Men movies and now they're
changing that up so yeah dude I'm very
excited for it I think it's going to be
next I think it's gonna be fun it's
gonna be fun next photo will be him
wearing the mask I think I think they're
kind of teased the uh the the thing off
and then they they seem to be really
smart at maintaining hype for this film
that then not dropping massive things
but they're doing something every couple
of weeks to just kind of keep you
interested and invested and it feels
like we're back in the good old days
Greg of Multiverse of Madness and no way
home hype and we're gonna make a video a
week about it yeah man it's so [__]
cool I mean it feels like the
announcement was just so it doesn't feel
like doesn't it feel like the
announcement that like wolverines
returning that that video that they did
I feel like that just happened like not
long ago and now we're like this far
along it's it's pretty crazy how uh how
we're here now well I'm excited a lot of
people didn't even know whether they
should report on this on YouTube because
of how the the league came out it looked
like it was like a behind the scenes
thing where they've just kind of
someone's leaked it uh but yeah Hugh
Jackman posted it on his Instagram and I
quickly updated my thumbnail make it
look relevant smart man smart man yeah
no thanks to you I got to have a
successful live stream
um
it's funny like this this morning for
people who don't know I was running this
stream was that uh I was telling Paul
like all right what are the stories you
want to talk about I really want to
research what they are beforehand and
then I I went to the so when I go to the
gym my process Every Morning has been I
go to the gym I go to the sauna put on
some headphones I meditate in the sauna
then I go work out after I was done
meditating Paul tells me
um I also got this the we also got this
Wolverine thing I'm like what wolverine
he messages me and well and I see it I'm
like what and then I called up uh Coy
and I was like you gotta come over right
now we got to do something about this
and so I had to like jet home totally
skip my workout and everything I did not
have a 10k run like you it's I ran home
and and uh streaming are doing well and
even even though it ended like a little
over an hour ago I'm still seeing that
this hour and a half stream got
6.3 K views in the last hour so thank
you Paul I completely missed the news
because I was too busy trying to get my
health in order
um but thank you thank you I have to
thank you speaking of Health I have to
keep turning my mic down because I'm
coughing away here so uh we'll wrap it
up there I think we'll cover everything
let's wrap it up we're covering oh man
ended on a much more positive no you
know when when we first came into the
podcast I was thinking oh it's gonna be
another week where we'll just talk about
how much we hate everything in our
Disney destroyed everything but you know
what we had lots of nice things to say
which I'm glad because I prefer these
more positive things so yeah I hope you
guys have enjoyed it what do you mean or
negative for 40 minutes of it uh but
yeah please leave a comment below if
you've been enjoying the show you can
find us on all podcasts well not all of
them but Apple Spotify Amazon everyone's
podcast we're gonna be on all the
podcasts
and thank you for all the support as
well it's been great I mean we've done
like the first month first of all months
out the way now and me and Greg were
like oh we can't actually believe how
you know it's doing a lot better than we
thought so yeah thanks a lot much
appreciated
um
I hope you enjoy my leg that's been in
frame this whole time I didn't notice
that until right now it's my little
hairy enjoy it baby
you won't be seeing it next week you'll
need to put some super chats in and
super thanks to say that if you want
your scumbags uh so yeah if you want to
support us go to shopzeroedition.com you
can buy merch from Greg you can buy
Metro meal like the heavy cap you can
buy it on there
um we appreciate all you guys as well we
love you you know we're like Tom Cruise
we we genuinely love you guys and you
make the show every week
um and thanks so much so yeah see you
guys next time same bat Time same bat
channel channel you take care yourself
peace and let us know your thoughts on
Mission Impossible if you've seen it as
well love you goodbye